first of all I want to look you in the
eyeballs and be like holy bejesus your
emmy-winning Darren Criss yes I get that
superlative now it's on for the
superlative are you so excited yeah whoo
what are you looking at I'm very excited
obviously so I would like us to do you
know an Emmy for eating a German no a
text message I sent you on I think is
July 14 okay the day of the Emmy
nomination it says you say wait I said
um I start it well I said oh yeah I said
congratulations Darren on your Emmy
nominee nation and I wrote girl with one
two three four five modest ours thank
you so much three exclamation points
which I didn't think was enough not
enough explanation and I said I'm so
happy for you and maybe one day you can
be an Emmy winner like I'm just chasing
your tails man well thank you I'm glad
to be in your stratosphere chase in your
bows first of all and you watch it sir
you looked generally gobsmacked and so
surprised this is the toughest category
of the night so I mean you say so
I'll take it I certainly I feel like
everybody's category it feels like the
toughest toughest I think leading up to
it it's just looking to the eyes of
everybody else yeah everybody is just on
the worst edge you can possibly imagine
I'm a pretty composed calm dude but it's
just excruciating waiting for it to hear
what happens they call your name and
what goes through your head holy but you
can bleep it right right and yours in
the ten seconds when you stand up and
then you walk to the stage it's going to
I'm praying that I can be articulate and
concise and say what I want to say in
the very little time that I have I'm my
father's son that there's a zero
tolerance policy forums and likes and
unnecessary words which I am definitely
a criminal offender of and so is there
anyone you forgot is there anything
you're like oh man what's great is they
give you a chance to say things
backstage which is
I waited on a lot I did a lot so I like
I thanked a lot of people and also the
cool thing was regardless would happen
tonight I kind of wear my heart in my
sleeve as you know so I like to thank
and appreciate people in real time that
regardless of what happened like they
know they know that I appreciate them
and one of the moments of the night and
it's trending on Twitter which you
probably haven't looked at your phone
knowing you know you know listen you and
your fiance you're quite private you
keep things really private and you
thanked her at the end you almost had
tears in her eyes she had tears in her
eyes it was just such a moment everybody
talking about it I'm a sucker for a
romantic flourish it was a romantic
flourish did you have that plan did you
think about it beforehand Morris have
been thinking about it for a while
didn't mess it up you didn't mess it up
and now the next thing is like a wedding
so I think you're good yep what year
2018 what a crazy year
[Music]
[Applause]